hi everyone it's jerry i have a fun game
to share with you in this one this is
the game between rey enigma playing on
the white end
a finalist on the show
spain's got talent and rey enigma is
playing against the legendary anatoly
karpov
the 12th world chess champion
this is a fast game a blitz game each
player only has three minutes each to
make all their moves i'll have a link to
the video in the description if you'd
like to check out this final episode of
spain's got talent
and i had to watch it in slo-mo in order
to track down all 83 moves of this
three-minute game so
if you're quick with math you'll know
that both players are on average
ripping off these moves once every about
two seconds so
really flying here
i'll be making some light comments along
the way and in the end
i can't seem to get away from doing this
little tale of the tape we'll get to see
in other words the quality of play in
this game
and it was far from flawless there was
in fact a surprising back to back
blunder in this one
so this setup that white is employing is
one i've
gone with myself many a times it is
super solid
but there is a great deficiency
and that deficiency is
eventually you run out of ways to
improve your position piecewise and pond
wise
black does not experience
this issue
black is able to play with the pawns on
the queen side b5 is the start of this
and because of this break on the queen
side a target is created in white's camp
on the queen side
what target is this that i'm speaking of
in this particular case
it's b2
a point that's now in the crosshairs and
this now forces white into a defensive
posture the knight has to run in reverse
in order to babysit the pawn
we have a knight exchange the queen is
looking to slip into h7
easily offset
with the knight on f6 a very stable
piece especially now that there is not a
dark square bishop around or a knight
close by to rattle its post
there's some pressure now on g2
convenient reply by the knight the queen
is now assisting in defending b2
black presses on the queen side further
c4 is a nice reply
pressure on d4 now
that's defended in the following way
first retreating the bishop
rook goes back to the eighth rank
d4 is now secure
and black makes sure that these pawns
stay disjointed
given a move i think b3 would be a nice
move to get in to strengthen
that c4 pawn and maintain this duo
from here white presses in the center
grab some space
bishop b5 queen f3 a good defensive move
a knight if allowed to get to f5
there's tactics right around the corner
maybe a capture here maybe a timely
check
so the knight is neutralized by the
bishop
bishop for knight exchange black
preferring this strong knight over the
bishop in this environment
queen to b4 there's now a threat on g4
the only way to defend his bishop f5
nice centralization by black and what is
this back-to-back blunder i spoke of at
the start of the video
well it is right around this point here
black is
uh now regaining the pawn with knight
takes d5
after check queen g3 knight f4 is a big
big blunder
that was not capitalized on
we could have very well seen the game
end
at this moment right here rook e3
and
white will be winning a piece
where do you move the queen and defend
the rook it's only this square but after
rook takes rook queen takes rook
there goes the knight and the game
rookie 3 was not played instead rook f3
and the knight simply moves
we have a queen exchange and now a
technical phase
bishop versus knight position
equal material
super solid structure and now
the black king is going to find it much
easier to approach the center
this guy is way out of play
this pawn was poison by the way you
can't take
because of this
fork on d5 so king f8
now it is a threat now it's defended the
king continues to improve the white king
is far away from helping out
there's a fun little tactic here by
black
if he wanted it he could play rook g1
and after it captures
knight f3 you get the piece back
and then i believe soon you'll be
hunting the b3 pawn
king b4
king c3
crushing move the rook is now dead
there's no safe squares for the rook
in the computer's eyes best is to go
ahead and grab the knight
i believe the practical decision here
is to not
uh give black a fast not not give black
a
past pawn so easily black would get that
if you go ahead and take the knight so
the attempt here was a practical one
rook to e2 and after knight takes rook
the king at least
goes towards the center this is now
completely gone for white but
as mentioned this is a super fast game
uh not a lot of time
in this one in fact as soon as this
final pawn is captured
the one on
b4
each player only has eight seconds left
to complete the game
and in the end with this 83 mover
we have
rey enigma
just a tiny bit faster
than anatoly karpov in this one
black
ran out of time but since black
since white doesn't have any
way to possibly win this position the
end result was
a draw
so
i found this to be uh quite interesting
just a you know a fun game i wanted to
see that
quality of play i wanted to check out
the moves first of all and yeah the
quality of play
on this one in the end we can see far
from
flawless here we go
uh many ups and downs to this one
and this was the big
big opportunity right here
after knight to f4 white had a winning
shot with rook to e3 missed that
and never had a winning attempt
and then it was the 12th world champion
who is winning at the very end but
ran out of time so the end result
a thai ball game so in the end
having a look at the average centipalm
loss this is code for quality of play
the lower the number the better
is the
is the quick
explanation a 36 for ray enigma and a 25
for the 12th world chess champion
anatoly karpov so again just a fun game
i wanted to share that one with you and
maybe you
found it interesting feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comments section below
and hope you found it
a little fun that's all for now take
care bye
you